Wonderful, wonderful to see all of
you are mostly unfamiliar faces,
a few familiar ones. Uh, and that's great.
It's just really nice to see a lot of
not people say, oh, it's, you know,
it's him again,
a lot of people for whom this,
some of these ideas and certainly the
content of our new book is going to be a
fresh and new.
So I want to put it all into context
for you and then we're all going to die
then. So we think about
marketing, we think about what,
what people say about it,
what people do about it.
And it's this,
and it's very troubling because
so much, uh, you know, when,
when we talk about marketing,
we talk about the stuff that marketers do.
We obsess over action.
Okay.
It's just all these tactical
kinds of things out there,
but very often lost in the
conversation is who we do it too.
Or I'd rather say who we do it with it,
it's almost an afterthought.
We have all of these shiny objects,
many of which were invented and, and,
and promoted right through to this, this
company here. And we're just, you know,
out there playing with toys. And I
always found that very troubling, uh,
at for kind of obvious reasons as well
as some subtle ones that we really want
to spend a little bit more
time thinking about them.
And that motivated the first book that
I wrote back in 2012 and it was really
nice to kind of get people to focus a
little bit more on the whole customer
thing. I, and it was, it was a very nice
success. We sold over 30,000 copies of it.
Um, but even then it didn't
quite do the job. You see,
the problem is the too many
people would read the title,
they wouldn't read the subtitle, they'd
read the title and then say, Aha,
I know exactly what you're talking about.
And I fully agree it's all about this.
We put the customer at the
center of everything we do.
And that just kills me because
that's not what we're talking about.
And maybe it's my fault for
choosing a really bad title,
but it's really less about the customer.
And it's more about an appreciation of
this wide variety of customers and which
ones, the ones we really do
want to focus on. So again,
the book was a nice way
to start the conversation,
but I spent so much of my time talking
about what I don't mean by customer
centricity.
And one thing I surely don't mean is
that the customer is always right and we
will do anything for you.
We're going to hire an army of Ninjas
to make sure that every need you have is
met. Every problem you have is solved.
That's not what I'm talking about.
But I'm also not talking about
the opposite ends of the spectrum,
which is we've got the customers we want,
we've got the customers who don't want,
let's get rid of them. Life will be much
easier. Okay. That, that has problems too.
And I can, I don't want to go into
the details. If you want, you can,
you can pick up the old book.
And then maybe the main,
and the whole reason I wrote the book to
go back to the research that I do is to
get people to get companies
to stop focusing on the
past and spent a little bit
more time obsessing over the future.
So instead of focusing on
historic profitability,
let's think about this idea
of customer lifetime value.
And is it fair to say
that every one of you,
whether you're working with these models,
are not at least has those letters,
whether they're cov or LTV as, as part
of your, your vocabulary, you know,
you're at least conversant with the bait
that that by itself is a really great
thing.
So,
so part of it is overcoming myths and
misconceptions about what we mean by
customer centricity. And part of it is
we just didn't go far enough with it.
That book was all about definition.
It was all about motivation.
It was all about aspiration.
It was just kind of laying out just a
vision of what the world could look like.
If we had a magic wand and could
wave it over each customer's head,
but it kind of stopped short of specifics.
Uh,
and so that's really where we want to go.
So how do we really do this stuff?
How do we communicate it internally,
externally, and how do we demonstrate
that it's actually worthwhile?
Or is it just another marketing
flavor of the month kind of thing.
And it too will pass.
We don't believe that at all.
And so we really wanted to find ways to
really move this conversation forward.
Again, not just in terms of definitions
and motivations, but in terms of actions.
And so, uh, so Sarah Tom's enters
the picture because, um, uh,
she and I developed this really
great customer centricity simulation.
A lot of you have done some kind
of business simulation game.
We have the product and let's figure out,
you know, with the product, you know,
which segments that we're going to sell
it to and how much money we're going to
spend it on the product. And it gets
back to all that marketing mix, four P's,
tactical kind of stuff.
Well,
how about a simulation where it's
your job to grow is profitable,
a customer base as possible. The product
is secondary, the customers are primary.
So that really helped up. That started
to, to move the conversation along,
but there's still a lot of room to go
there. We're trying every possible thing,
but we just need kind of broader
and deeper adoption across firms.
And I look at all the different reasons
why people start to think about this
stuff. Is it, hey,
we can make more money if we have our
CLV magic wand and we allocate our
resources appropriately. Or is it,
hey, nothing else is working for us.
And out of sheer desperation,
what the hell? We'll try that too.
Whatever the reason we need to find a
way and we need to find a metaphor to try
to get people on board with this stuff.
And so all the time I'm just
thinking about, you know,
tools and models and
simulations and stuff like that.
Sarah Tom's enters the picture
literally and figuratively, uh, to,
to give us a really nice way to kind of
take the conversation to a higher level.
Exactly. So when Pete and I
were writing this book together,
a lot of our conversation was about
the call to action that we wanted to
generate around customer centricity.
And when
you think about this opportunity and
desperation that really is mounting in the
marketing and sales field,
it really,
it reminded me of what happened in the
mid nineties in software development.
So I entered the tech
field in the mid nineties,
the dawn of.com.
A really,
really a wonderful time
to be an entrepreneur.
I started my first tech company and like
most entrepreneurs entering technology
at the time was incredibly
opportunity, uh, um, uh,
excited and ready for the challenge.
The problem was in reality when I started
working with my clients is that the
first thing I would be asked
for is a lot of documentation.
I was following the waterfall process.
Like I was being told to my
tech team was really, uh,
not able to deliver in
the same way and to the,
the objectives of what we were
trying to do as a business.
And one of the problems was
with a technology at the
time was we were following
old processes that were quite literally
decades old. They were not fast,
they were not agile.
And they were really being dictated
to us by bureaucracy such as the u s
government, who at the time was
the largest developer of software.
So a great example of this,
when the space shuttle went, uh,
into the stratosphere in 1982,
it had technology on board that
was quite literally from the 60s.
Software took sometimes between
six and a two decades to deliver.
And what that led to was the software
development crisis in the 1990s.
So this is where hardware
pcs were sitting on desktops.
They were moving into homes and software
quite literally could not keep up.
So what we saw here is this timeline
where there were a few rogue software
development teams who were like,
this gotta be a better way.
They were probably looking at Deming
and what he was doing with the iterative
processes and quality
assurance and in manufacturing,
which was more of an iterative approach,
a more lightweight approach.
And what really started to happen with
these pioneers in technology was they
decided that it was time to all come
together to draw a line in the sand or the
snow because they all came
together in a snowbird,
Utah in 2001 and they decided to declare
their independence from the old ways of
doing software.
And here you have the agile manifesto,
which was written in 2001
now it's kind of quirky and,
and this is still the
website today by the way.
It looks still very 1996 or 2001 they
wrote a clear definition for a vision and
what needed to be done in
software in particular.
And what was the way forward for how
to develop a way that would be lean,
a way that would bring the,
the customer or the user to the center
of the design a way that was more
iterative so that they could course
correct and most importantly so that they
could communicate with one another.
And also with the business
stakeholders who would, you know,
software is being developed for.
And this was an amazing time for all of
us who are in software at the time when
we saw this manifesto come to life and
when we started to see it being adopted.
So stupid question really did agile work,
you guys are all looking at me
like of course it did sir. Um,
so here's some study information from a
Gartner study and other global studies
that have been done on agile in 2018.
No surprise here,
97% of organizations have adopted even
a small amount of agile within their
organization.
What we really love for Pete and I are
really excited about is this down here is
that is no longer just a
software process or approach.
It's now being adopted by financial teams,
by middle management teams.
It's been adopted as
a way by lean startup.
It's been adopted as a way
forward to deliver great stuff.
It is product centric.
I will admit that as well.
And of course I had to put some Google
search results also in these Gartner
studies.
When agile projects are implemented,
they're three times more
successful for complex projects,
six times more successful.
So clearly this was the right way to go.
What you see here with
these adoption curves, uh,
since the 19 hundreds and what if any
of you have been in a marketing class or
in a business class?
What you're seeing is they're speeding up.
Adoption is faster, right? Here
is where the manifesto happened.
And for a lot of you you're probably
thinking, well, it's just, you know,
processing powers better,
we're getting better at tech.
But what I actually believe,
somebody who's been in the technology
sphere now for over 20 years,
it's really been this, this shift in
how we, we create technology together.
And I believe that the agile manifesto
was that sort of ignition point,
that it was that tipping point that
allowed us to be able to support the
innovation and now the adoption
that has gone along with it.
So let's take that real story and now
use it as a metaphor for kind of the data
analytics customer centricity thing.
Cause right now a lot of companies
believe that we're on the verge of another
tipping point because we have so much
data, we have so much computing power.
We have so much analytical capabilities
that would just going to combine all
this stuff together and money is just
going to come raining down from the sky.
We're going to see the same kind of
just break through in terms of success,
not in terms of hard goods or,
or you know, or, or, or services.
But in terms of just our, our
analytical and customer centric smarts,
while it's not going to happen,
uh,
and I've really learned that
the hard way because again,
for years and years and years I've
been going to companies and saying,
here's the CLV model.
Please use it.
And not only was it hard
to get adoption on it,
but even when companies would adopt it,
so how do we make money on it?
So I really believe it's less about the
ingredients and more about the process.
And so staying with this metaphor where
it would kind of talking about how do we
make that process go better?
And so we've had all these conversations
very often around the sim and so on.
And so, you know, you know, how do
we get that overall call to action?
And of course it's up to sour times
to come up with the right answer.
Let's create our own manifesto.
And so I'm very pleased, very,
very pleased to present
for the very first time to,
to an audience here in the
u s are you ready for it?
Please?
Good enough.
The
customer centricity manifesto.
So literally taking a
page out of their book,
making it just a little
bit prettier, um, and, and,
and basically coming up with an organizing
set of principles and then underlying
specific tactical practices,
which is what we're going to talk
about with you this afternoon to say,
let's all agree on this.
Let's make this happen and let's figure
out both how to get buy in internally as
well as externally.
So we spent a bunch of time,
and I'll be super honest with you,
we basically had this sim,
we put together a basically
a software manual.
We'll just to kind of help people play
the game. We said, that's not enough.
We want to help them play
the game smarter. And again,
we realized it was more than just
saying, here's how you calculate Cov. Um,
it was more about the mindset that
you're going to take on when you approach
this kind of exercise, whether it's
simulator or whether it's real.
If you're interested,
you can go to customer
centricity manifesto.org
signed the manifesto show that
you agree,
spread the Gospel about it and that's
what we want to talk about is to basically
take each one of these four principles
over here and just bring it to life.
So let's start with this
first one right here.
The idea of we're going to
really celebrate customer
heterogeneity over averages
so you know when you start thinking about,
okay, all right, all right, I got ya.
Customers are different from each other.
What immediately comes to mind is that
that that pain and suffering that you
went through in your introductory
statistics course where that professor and
pretty much every
professors since then said,
everything follows a normal
distribution and so stands to reason.
That would be the same
thing with your customers.
They're going to get this nice
symmetric mix. You've got the good ones,
he got the not so good ones.
You got this big lump in the middle
and depending on just how it's shaped,
you might say,
you know,
there's so many over here that we
really can focus on the average.
Well the problem is this never happens.
That's just not true. And it's something
that I've known for quite some time,
but it really,
really crystallized are through my first
startup company called Zodiac that some
of you might be familiar with. Don't
Google it now cause it's gone. I'll,
I'll tell you why.
Uh,
and basically what we were doing is
we were working with lots of different
companies, wonderful variety of
companies, products and services, B,
two B and B to c, domestic and
international, big and small.
And we'd would just calculate the COVs
and say, here you go, now go make money.
And the distribution of COVs that we'd
see would pretty much always look like
this. Very much not normal. And
it's not only that it's not normal,
but it also gives you a lot of
specific advice and direction.
Like who are these customers over here?
What makes them different
from everybody else?
And how can we find more like them? That's
what customer centricity is all about.
And so recognizing the nature of this
distribution is really critical to kind of
drive you in that direction and hopefully
motivate you to look for this kind of
stuff. And then of course,
act on it. Um, the, the,
the bottom line on the Zodiac thing
for those of you don't know is, um, uh,
just a couple of months ago we actually
sold the company to Nike and now they're
doing just an amazing, wonderful
things with CLV. You know, again,
a company I used to be
very product centric,
but now doing just incredible things by,
by understanding their customers and
doing all the stuff that we're talking
about here. Kind of really nice story for
you. It's more than just distributions,
it's more than just math.
It's about how do we get other people
to celebrate customer heterogeneity did
some work with a small B2B
manufacturer down in Norfolk, Virginia.
So kind of a very different
kind of company than,
than a lot of companies that you would
think about when we're talking about CLV.
Uh,
and the CEO found it very frustrating
that after I had this session and kind of
get everyone all juiced up and
jazzed up about customer centricity,
that he listened to the conversations
that were taking place a day, a week,
a month later,
and everyone was still talking about
the customer or the average customer.
We found it frustrating. He said, tell
you what, this is what we're going to do.
So he put a fish bowl right there in
the company lunch room and he said,
I want all of you to listen.
I want all of you to police each other
at any time you hear a colleague referred
to the customer in a singular manner
and they're not referring to a singular
customer. Anytime he'd be able
to just talk about the customer,
the average customer, you
call him on it, say I got you.
And they have to put a
dollar in the fishbowl.
And it was a really fun way to get people
to really think about this one idea
all the time. Nothing about tactical
execution, just the mindset.
And in no time at all.
They had a fish bowl filled with dollars,
very visible for everyone to see.
And at the end of the quarter or whenever
it was, the CEO said, you know what?
We're going to have a party now using
all that money and what is it that we're
going to celebrate
customer heterogeneity? So it comes
full circle like that. And it's just a,
just a clever little way.
I want everyone to go out there and buy
a fish ball right now for yourself or
for your clients. Um, but it's just
a clever little way to say, again,
it's not just about geeky math stuff,
it's about figuring out how
to get that message across.
That's principle number one.
Let me hand things back to Sarah.
Let's keep on going. Okay, so friend,
customer heterogeneity. Principle
number two
is cross functional uses of
CLV over siloed applications.
So when Pete and I set out to write this
book, it was incredible. It was really,
really important to us.
We didn't again,
create something that's just going
to sit right in the marketing silo.
This is something that we need to ignite
conversations across the functional
areas. Uh, it's why when
you delve into the book,
we have parts where we're talking about
how you engage with your technology
teams and you talk about data,
how you work with finance,
how you work with the other
areas to really start to
get that conversation going.
Like, uh, Pete's last example,
talking about making sure that folks
aren't thinking just about the customer.
So I want to do here is just share a
couple of really interesting examples.
These are not examples in the
book brand new for you folks. Um,
batteries plus bulbs,
no prizes if you can guess what they sell.
So they have been, uh, they are
here in the United States. They are,
uh, the 700 us, excuse me, 700 stores.
And, um, they are just a
pretty usual hard goods,
brick and mortar selling. What do
you think? Batteries and bulbs.
Exactly. Good job guys. So, um,
what I like about this example in Pete
and I both know the former, uh, head, uh,
chief customer analytics,
a gentleman and he has shared
with us some incredible, um,
evolution of the use of CLV within
their company. So they started small,
they started experimental,
and it's now grown into being a cross
functional experience for them when they
think about their business,
when they think about their customers
and how they engage with their customers
in different ways based on CLV higher
value customers are gonna want to be
engaged with differently than their
lower value customers, for example.
So when they have their, uh, customers
coming to them through their website,
through their call centers,
through retail,
they have ways of capturing
that behavioral data.
So for example,
using a natural language
API that's collecting all of
this behavioral data about
their customers and they know which
ones are going to behave a certain way,
are more likely to have higher value
versus which ones are behaving a certain
way, are going to have lower
and middle, a tiered value.
And all that gets pumped up
every single day into salesforce.
And by the next day they've,
they've created lists sorted
by CLV for their sales force.
Those are now target lists that they can
go after and then they cycle back the
performance of that,
those lists back to those various areas.
And they improve on those
algorithms all the time.
So it's a nice iterative
process where they're,
they're really leveraging CLV and
not just that the company's been very
successful.
They're constantly expanding.
They're looking at mom and pop shops that
they can acquire and they use CLV for
that. That's one of their key indicators
for where are they going to go,
which store are they going to buy?
Which store are they going to put in?
Second,
really cool example.
Little bit more exciting maybe for some
of you than batteries and bulbs is um,
electronic arts. So gaming
company, we do actually, uh,
speak about sort of their origin
story as far as customer centricity.
They are very,
very mature.
And the customer centricity space as
far as how they are leveraging CLV and
their data analytics teams are actually
embedded into their gaming studios so
that when they do game launches,
they're feeding back that
game data and those CLV data,
real time to the studio
developers and letting them know,
where are you successful
with this feature, where you
successful with this game,
et cetera. So last year in November,
they had command and conquer rivals,
which just launched and they knew that
they didn't know anything about really
their customer base when they launched.
And so they're advertising looked
like this. So this was November,
2018 you'll notice that we have a
pretty good, uh, gender representation.
They're playing around with some
imagery as far as some of the, uh,
the different weaponry, et
cetera. Fast forward one month,
they're starting to collect initial
customer data and information.
By December, 2018 they've started to
make some small adaptations to that.
You can see it here. And then by
December, 2018 and then, sorry,
by January,
2019 they realized something,
they realized that who was bubbling to
the top as far as CLV where a teenage
boys in North America.
So you'll see here women really have
fallen out of being represented in their
ads. You'll also see that there's a lot
more left to right because of the left to
right reading where the call to
action is, et Cetera, et cetera.
So this is another great
example of acquisition where
it CLV is being leveraged
to help guide the way.
Yeah.
But sometimes the best, uh, examples,
it's not just getting smarter about
which kinds of customers to acquire it.
How much did you spend to do
so and where to find them.
But it's what do we do with
the existing customers?
Cause this has been kind of a,
a bit of a mass for a lot of companies
because companies know what to do with
those existing customers when it comes
to trying to make them more valuable.
And they'll ask those two
great American questions,
which you all know so well.
Do you want fries with that?
And do you want to supersize it,
which of course we're using as accurate,
but kind of cutesy
versions are proxies for
what's that top on? Well, gotta
be careful about it, right?
That the top one is going
to be cross selling. People
who buy this also buy that.
And the bottom one will be upselling.
And the problem today is that this
is how we fattened up our customers,
whether it's like what they're eating
or what we're presenting to them. Um,
and that's all companies know.
And so taking all of this technology
just to figure out how to cross sell and
upsell better, faster, more
effectively, more thinking,
can we do better than that?
Can't we come up with just different
ways of kind of growing the value of
customers are going to value
of the customer base. Um,
outside of just doing old school
stuff a little bit differently.
So we took a step back and rethought
about these kinds of tactics through the
lens, through the mindset
of customer centricity.
And we came up with two dimensions.
They'll kind of obvious in hindsight,
but they're just not, they don't
show up a lot in practice. Uh,
the first dimension would be which
kinds of customers are we talking about?
Uh, either, uh, uh,
making more valuable or
just just holding onto that.
As Sarah has said and as
it's entirely obvious,
the kinds of tactics we use should vary
based on whether we're talking about
really valuable customers or so.
So ones that should be
explicitly taken into account,
not just to say which kind of cross sell
message we're going to be using for you,
but what kind of overall tactic we
should be deploying different kinds of
tactics for different kinds of
customers. That's number one. Number two,
when it comes to
retention and development,
you kind of get the basic
idea of the right way,
which is development is let's take those
existing customers and make them more
valuable. Retention is, let's
hold on to the customers we have,
but there's a lot of crossover,
especially in the tactical execution of
those things where they kind of start to
blur together.
We want to break it apart and make it
more explicit about what kind of strategic
objective do we really have in mind?
Are we playing off fence or are
we playing defense? And again,
for which kinds of customers.
So if you take these two dimensions,
you get what every marketing professor
is contractually obligated to share with
you a two by two matrix.
And so basically we were trying to
come up with an overall are going to
organizing framework that again,
from the customer centric standpoint,
we asked the question which kind of tactic
or are we gonna use at which time for
which kinds of a strategic objective
and for which kinds of customers,
and I'm not going to take you
through the whole thing, but,
but we just want to bring clarity, uh, not
only to which tactic going to use when,
but even what do we exactly mean by
these different kinds of tactics.
So just as one example, there's one
area over here. It's not your idea of,
of premium offerings.
You've got these high value customers.
Don't give them a buy nine get one
free thing. I mean really you can't,
you do better than that. These are
the people who, for whatever reason,
very strongly identify with you.
They like the products you sell that
like the way that you sell them.
They resonate with the brand,
with the people for a variety of reasons.
These are the folks who are going to go
through the gates of hell to stay with
you. And you know what? They don't mind
going even deeper into the relationship.
They don't mind paying more,
not that you want to gouge them,
you don't want to risk the relationship.
But lots of opportunities
starting with some of the,
the real well known ones
like linked in premium.
So how many of you are
linked in premium folks?
Raise your hand and proudly if you, if
you're a link in print, this is my point,
okay? It is a premium service.
It is not for everybody,
okay. But for those one or two
people who put their hands up,
linkedin means a great deal to you,
right?
And so there's lots of other companies
out there that have been a little bit too
shy to do this. Um, uh, just, just, uh,
don't you think our president would
pay a premium to kind of, I'm just,
I'm just saying and I'm,
and I'm not joking about that.
There's a lot of people out there,
myself included who actually would,
would happily pay whatever
it would be seven,
$8 a month and to get extra value added
services that maybe they could justify
offering to everybody.
A recent example would be Lulu Lemon.
Lulu Lemon recently announced what the
press is calling a new loyalty program,
but it has a little twist to it because
you have to pay a bunch of money up
front to be part of it. That's not a
loyalty program. That's a premium surface.
So let's bring clarity to what,
what label we're using on which tactic
and at what time we're using it.
And I'm not going to go into the rest of
the details here. Read the book. Page 44.
It's all right there. Um, but,
but really using this as the lens to
look at a lot of the tactical things that
companies are doing,
customer experience and just so many
other things that that are going on out
there and where does it fit and
does it make sense to use it or not?
So that's just giving you kind
of the tip of the iceberg on,
on a broad variety of, of different kinds
of applications of all the CLD stuff.
And it's going to be, you know, more than
just your standard kinds of, you know,
how much should we pay for the customer
kind of thing that there's much more to
say. Point number three,
this one over here,
we want companies to choose their
metrics very, very carefully. You see,
the problem is very often even
companies that are kind of data driven,
metric oriented or choosing the metrics
that reflect their strategic orientation,
which means they're very much
focused on well, volume and cost.
And a really good example that might be
surprising to some of you just went over
here.
People have this one over here.
So let's look at the world's
most valuable brands. Right?
And I can show this with pride over
here cause you know, the Google is,
is towards the top of the list
and you know, people just like,
I could just leave this up here,
you know,
for the rest of our time you can
just stare out it quite happily.
But I actually have a bunch
of concerns about it. Uh,
I think they're very serious concerns
and I think that companies are just
obsessing over this kind of thing cause
it's kind of shiny and cool but it's not
aligned with customer centric thinking.
Now having said that,
I'm not throwing branding under the
bus branding still really important and
that's what I want to do here.
I want to talk both about what are the,
how should we be thinking about metrics
and what is the role of branding in the
customer centric enterprise.
So what am I some of my concerns about
this idea of brand equity? Number one,
I think there's kind of a bit of a
backwards causality thing going on.
Like Google was not near the top of the
list back in the late nineties it wasn't
until it became a behemoth company
and then, Oh then you know,
everyone knows the brand. It's top of
mind. Oh, lots of brand equity there.
So I think a lot of that brand
equity really just reflects volume.
Just the overall size of the company.
You know,
you don't see anyone showing to you,
here's a chart of the companies
with the highest average customer,
customer lifetime value. You
know, you don't see that one.
And that is what I want to
start to talk about. Okay.
To kind of put those kinds
of metrics front and center.
And secondly is this point over here,
can we really measure brand equity
that with that kind of precision,
you could go back to that slide and you
see that they're measuring the value of
the Google brand or apple or
whomever else with you know,
six significant figures.
I defy you to find a single
chief financial officer on
the planet who would say,
yeah, I buy that. I mean,
we'll all agree that the Google
brand is incredibly valuable.
We'll all agree that the
brand and everything that
it stands for could well be
worth on the order of hundreds
of millions of dollars,
hundreds of billions of dollars.
But could we really specify at
the six or seven decimal places?
I don't think so. So we have a
couple of objectives over here,
which is to try to come up with metrics
that we really can trust that we really
can share across the organization.
So there's a bunch of marketers,
a flattering themselves with it,
but also reflect more about customer
equity instead of brand equity. You know,
in my first book I had a picture to look
to kind of like this and it basically
said, you know, customer
equity is not for everybody.
There are some companies where
it's going to be hard to measure,
it's going to be hard to leverage it.
And there's going to be other companies
out there that are just great at
building, you know, terrific
brands, good for them. You know,
there's fine let them be, they don't
have to do the customer centric thing.
But as time goes by,
as I have these conversations with,
with lots and lots of executives,
kind of changing my tune on it because
I've come to realize that a lot of the
things that could,
that that on the surface could lead
to a really strong brand but don't
necessarily show up in customer equity.
I don't believe it.
But what are the kinds of things like,
oh we can go out there and
we can hire great employees,
we can get special tax breaks and
other privileges from government,
things that that don't necessarily show
up immediately as more customers buying
more stuff at higher margins. But if you
think about it over the long run view,
which is kind of what we like to have.
So what if you can hire better
employees? Big Deal, good for you.
Unless those employees can help
you bring in more customers,
will buy more often at higher margins.
There's no equity in it.
So pretty much all of the things that I
used to say belong over here really are
subsumed by this.
And so the,
the picture we have in the book now looks
a little bit more like this. Okay. And,
and so a couple of important
points about it. A number one,
the customer equity is,
is going to be a potentially larger
that it's going to subsume all of those
elements of brand equity and just a lot
of the boring transactional stuff. Uh,
number two,
there could still be some aspects of
brand equity that we don't pick up.
It's just not going to be that much.
Not going to be that
substantial but important.
Number three is that a huge chunk of the
customer equity will be associated with
the brand.
Having an awesome brand will enable you
to acquire better customers a little bit
more cheaply. It will enable you to hold
on to them a little bit longer with,
with, uh, with lower cost
to keep them around. So, so,
so branding absolutely helps maintain
and magnify that customer equity.
It's just that you can't
measure it directly.
It's just folded in to all of the
stuff that shows up in lifetime value.
And so a lot of people read,
read my first book and kind of took me
as a brand hater, uh, that, you know,
he's against branding. No,
no, no, no, no. I just,
I'm just concerned about brand
measurement and the kind of the, and the,
and the podium that we put it on. And
so the, the kind of happy middle ground,
uh, that I, and, and that's our have found
is this over here is that, as I said,
a branding is super hard
to measure by itself.
In many cases it's super hard to see the
specific effects that it will have on
different customers. So let's not
try to do all of that measurement.
It's just going to make us cool.
But it does show up in so many
ways and those are important ways.
And so the,
the metaphor that we'd like to use over
here is that branding is really the
lubrication for the
customer's centricity engine.
So you can't do the customer centric
thing as well as possible unless you have
branding that's going to help
you do acquisition, retention,
development employees, uh, and
all that stuff a lot better.
So it's important you
need to invest in it.
It's much harder to measure
the Roi on those investments.
And it might be for some,
you know,
kind of direct marketing
campaigns or something like that.
You need to run a lot of experimentation
to figure figure it out. Uh, but it,
so it's still there, but it's just an
overall component of customer equity.
We just want to change the way that
people are thinking about those kinds of
metrics. And a few are the metrics
to that are worth talking about.
Some I'm sure you're quite
familiar with. MM, definitely. So
recognize the fact that it's not a new
idea thinking about your customers and
different, you know, that they perform
differently, that they work differently.
This actually was first, uh,
from, uh, modern times anyway, uh,
launched in this book
by Frederick Reichheld.
So he's a bane consultant
principal at Bain,
and he wrote this book in 1996.
It's called the loyalty effect and
what he wanted to do in this book.
It's really explain that
there's a mechanism, there's,
there's a way that
customers behave and really,
instead of trying to push as much
product blindly to as many, you know,
faceless,
nameless customers,
well you really should be doing is looking
at the behaviors of your customers,
learning what those are and then working
to really reduce the friction in that
relationship. And what happens when you
reduce the friction in the relationship,
especially with your higher value
customers, is you grow their value.
And when you grow their value, you
reduce the costs that they, you know,
they cost you to have as their
customers. And as you, uh,
reduce the costs,
you have this virtuous cycle start to
happen where the next thing you know,
they see you as a trusted advisor and
they're going to start referring other
customers to you.
So in this book,
he Reichheld really was aiming to just
describe that this mechanism exists.
It's different for different
types of customers.
And it was really that first seed
of an idea that I think was going to
eventually lead to customer centricity.
So in his first book he was really
aiming to explain sort of the nature of
customers. And then fast forward
to 2006 and he released this book,
the ultimate question and what he was
driving at in this book was really
understanding how to measure that.
And so I'm sure you'll not be surprised
to see the measurement being net
promoter score.
So I know that there are probably a lot
of detractors in here as far as nps goes.
There definitely are some haters
and we want to recognize that.
But the reason Pete and I like this was
this was the first time nps really was
one of the first times that it elevated
this idea of customer differences in
sort of the, the, you know,
our, our business sense.
So let's look at nps through
a customer centric Lens.
So some of the reasons Pete
and I like a nps, number one,
it celebrates a customer heterogeneity.
Number two,
it gives an elite status to the promoters.
So in the equation,
the promoters definitely happened
elite status. Third, it's simple.
It's an easy way to have a
conversation about, you know,
your different customers
and it's an easy way to, uh,
really evaluate them and slice and
dice and look at them across different
segments to really understand your
customers more. Now we, again,
we recognize that, you know, nps
has been implemented blindly.
Pete and I would probably complain about
things like it's been implemented too
narrowly. There are ways
that it could be, uh,
looked at beyond referral
and they're really,
the biggest problem with nps is it
doesn't take into account value.
So it's missing a key component of
that relationship with the customer.
So this is a great step
in the right direction and
really understanding the, the,
the interplay between nps and CLV
is, uh, is a great area of, of,
of research that's going
on right now. Uh, but it,
it really does get to this idea that,
okay,
it's one thing to come up with the right
metrics that reflect customer centric
practices.
Uh,
but it's a whole nother thing to
figure out how to get 'em out there.
So people believe you that you
really are doing this kind of stuff.
And doing it well.
And you know what?
We understand that maybe you're not
maximizing your profits this quarter,
but by doing the right things and
in terms of customer centricity,
that is going to be so well worth
it in the long run. So, well,
let me just go through this fourth
point with a very interesting and very
contemporary case study. You all know
Wayfair online furniture company,
uh, as another good news and bad news
story. A first from Wayfair's perspective,
the good news,
look at those revenue numbers.
Everyone's dream come true.
That hockey stick,
convex curve revenues through the roof.
My concern,
going back to point number three,
is that this just reflects overall volume.
I want to know more about the
quality of those revenues.
Instead of just saying how many
dollars are flowing in the door.
I want understand the nature
of the customers who are
bringing in those dollars.
I mean,
you have to believe that a sale to a,
to a new unproven customer is going to
be different in terms of lifetime value
enhanced then the,
the,
the fourth sale to someone who's
been around with you before.
So let's peel that apart. And one of the
problems is with most companies, uh, it's,
it's just impossible to do.
So how would you be able to take all of
this revenue and decompose it into the
COVs?
Well,
one of the things that he give Wayfair
a lot of credit for is that they make it
easy. So if you look at that,
their own financial statements,
this is a paper that I
wrote with Dan Mccarthy.
We're basically using data from
Wayfair and from another company,
overstock.com that you might know,
that also reveals a lot of really
interesting metrics to the right kinds of
metrics that are external stakeholders
want to see and should demand to see,
well, here's their data. So in addition
to giving us revenues, okay, fine,
that's not surprising.
They give us a lot more metrics like how
many customers did we add this quarter?
Okay,
that's not that surprising.
A lot of companies will give us that kind
of metric, but again, it's not required.
Accounting Standards Boards
don't say anything about that.
Some companies just voluntarily
choose to put that out there.
This might help you
understand this better,
but it's the other two metrics
that really make them unique.
You can see him right here. One of them
is Cutie Oh quarterly total orders.
They are telling us how many orders
are being placed on their website every
quarter. This is all public data
and the last one over here, a you.
I bet you can guess what
that is. What is Aa? You
annual active users.
Again,
I take your silence as a, as a sign
that we have a long way to go here.
We really want to make these kinds of
metrics part of the everyday vocabulary
and we're not just waiting for some
companies to charitably provide them to us
for reasons I don't even understand,
but for investors, for analysts,
from marketing professionals to demand
them so we can really understand how
those dollars are working.
Here's the cool part about it.
You give me these metrics or you
can give him to Dan Mccarthy.
This was part of his dissertation and I
can peel back the onion and look at the
nature of heterogeneity.
This company almost as accurately as
if I had the raw transaction log data.
Now for Wayfair, I don't, and
they're not going to give it to me.
They don't like me very much
over there. You'll see why. Um,
but that's what we're going to do is we,
instead of just saying,
here's revenue today, this is what
revenue is going to be tomorrow.
We're going to peel it all back and
let's understand the components,
the customer centric components
of revenue. So that's forecast.
How many customers will we acquire?
How long will those
customers stay with us?
How many transactions will they make
over that horizon and how valuable will
those transactions be? I hope you agree
with me on two things. Number one,
those would be really good things to know.
Again,
as an outside evaluator of
the farm, you've got to tell
me that. And number two,
have you add all that stuff up?
That's revenue.
So we're going to come in
revenue from the bottom up.
So we're going to take all of this data,
these columns that you see over here,
and we're going to model it through may
of 2017 and we're going to show how well
we can capture all of these patterns.
So here's how many customers we've had
and here's the total orders down here is
revenue. But I want to emphasize that
we're not modeling revenue directly.
That's what the people on Wall Street
do. Where modeling, here we go again,
how many customers are going to acquire,
how long are they gonna stay,
how many transactions are going to make,
how valuable that will
those transactions B,
and then combining it all together to say
that's what we think revenue is. Okay,
so we're, we're, we're deriving this,
we're not modeling it directly and we're
doing a pretty good job of it gives you
a good feeling in the belly
that we could take this curve.
We can take these underlying components
and project them out into the future and
we can project them out pretty far.
Then we can do a little bit of accounting
stuff to turn it into an overall
corporate valuation. So that's what
we're going to do. So on the next slide,
I want to point out two things before I
had to dazzle you with it. Number one,
we're going to start with this curve
over here. We're going to say, all right,
hey look, we've captured revenue
through may of 2017 let's go beyond it.
So you're going to see that curve all
compressed and at 50 years to the right of
it if the projected years.
Number two,
we recognize that not
all models are perfect,
it's just that some suck less than others.
And so we're going to acknowledge that
there could be errors in each one of our
models. So we allow for each one of
our curves to be slightly different.
So I'm going to show you several
hundred maybe several thousand different
trajectories that Wayfair's revenue
could take on. And here it is.
There's the,
there's the revenues through middle
of 2017 and there a very bleak future.
Again,
I give this company a lot of credit for
successes to date and for the metrics
that they share,
but it is not a pretty picture that
acquisitions and growing too fast and too
expensive. Lee, they're acquiring a lot
of very bad customers and they're not,
they haven't established enough of
a base of repeat buying that when
acquisitions level off,
which they will do,
they must usually what happens with
most companies when acquisitions peak,
there's enough established base of
ongoing repeat buying that you don't even
notice it. I mean, did you even notice
when Amazon's acquisitions peaked? Nah,
because the repeat buying was
so high that it was all good.
This company will crash.
It might crash this year as some retail
experts are saying in my crash and I
don't know, our best guess is sometime
in the mid 20 twenty's, I don't know,
but they're, they're, they're,
they're just imbalanced and
their allocations and well,
let's take each one of these numbers
and turn it into evaluation. Here we go.
And May of 2017 the company
was trading for $65 a share.
We come up with a main stock price of 10
and where? Right. Well time will tell.
Interesting to see that there's the simple
academic paper had quite an impact on
the stock price
in September of 2017 the stock was trading
in the mid eighties the day the paper
came out,
wafer had the biggest drop in stock price
in a couple of years and it just kind
of kept on going from there and it was
just really interesting to see the way
that people picked up on it, including
our own Philly guy, Jim Kramer
say the poor think left.
He's totally into this one.
Struck again when he tweeted a support
of an academic paper published by
professors at Emory in the universe,
Pennsylvania,
Corey at the smartest piece
ever written on Wayfair.
It did the job cost waiting for the
punch from 83 to seven years of today.
What was so devastating about
a high level academic paper.
The professors tried to come up with a
way to pin a value on Wayfair's current
and future customers based
on how many I want to,
how much they make from these customers
versus how much they spend to acquire
them.
Let's think about this for a second.
Let me just kind of tone it down. Jim.
The professors said that they're going
to figure out the value of the company by
looking at the value of the customers
and the cost of acquisition.
Okay.
What's your reaction to that? I'll
tell you what your reaction should be.
Your actions should be,
Duh.
That's how every company should be valued.
Instead of is looking at this,
this almost meaningless
overall revenue stream,
let's decompose it into the
stuff that really matters.
It really reflects what this company's
all about and build it up from there.
So that's the kind of thing that
I've been really pushing both. Uh,
I'm primarily as a way just to kind of
make the customer centric thing happened.
But here's my new startup.
If you're interested in this,
and I'm not here to sell it,
but if you're interested in some of these
ideas about how we can revolutionize
finance through customer base corporate
evaluation to basically take these
principles of customer centricity and
bring them to a very different audience to
get the CFO and the VP of investor
relations onboard as well.
So tell me more about those methods
and hey you guys in marketing,
you might want to see these models
over here. The kind of interesting,
that's the conversation that
I want to create a and so,
so good and I hope it's been so far,
so good for all of you as well.
Those are our four principles of
our customer centricity manifesto.
Let me hand it over to Sarah to wrap
it up and then we'd love to get some
questions from you.
Awesome. Thanks Pete. Okay,
so beyond the manifesto,
just some quick quick takeaways for you.
So we'd like you to join the
customer centricity revolution.
It's why we wrote the book.
We hope you'll read the book.
It's really little easy to carry around
in your pocket and a nice quick read.
Uh, but really our goal was, like I said,
is to distill these ideas and provide
that call to action and not be kind of in
that academic sphere,
although it really is grounded in academic
research and also business research.
But to really give a clear roadmap for
how to implement customer centricity in
your organization. Second, we'd
love you to sign the manifesto.
Third, integrating, uh,
the essential frameworks that Pete and
I have been talking about here today.
Also in the book also, if you
Google Pete Fader, of course,
there are plenty of other pieces where,
where he's providing advice that a would
be incredibly useful for you to follow
into your everyday business practice.
The one thing that I've found really
interesting in this journey of customer
Centricity, I've had the opportunity
to interview a lot of folks, uh,
in the business world when we
were putting the book together.
Pete and I are writing articles currently.
Also putting this presentation together
is every single organization that I've
spoken to who are now mature in customer
centricity, they all started small.
They all started with
teeny tiny experiments.
Often it was actually middle managers or
data scientists who had an inkling that
something wasn't quite right and
there was ways to really define and,
and fine tune their strategies
around customer lifetime value.
When I talked to, uh, the
folks over at the La Dodgers,
they actually made a lot of mistakes for
number of years when they were trying
to experiment with CLV.
But those mistakes really have helped
them now where they are with their use of
um,
CLV and their business.
So it's really interesting and this is
a key point is living at experimenting.
Our Call to action in the book has
really quite literally diving in and just
start getting to work. And
the last but not least, um,
so I lead the simulation
team at the Wharton school.
The simulations really hold
a tremendous amount of power.
They provide folks with an
opportunity to roll up their sleeves,
think about something like a simulation,
a way to bring your teams together and
really experience what it's like, uh,
coming, becoming familiar with customer
centricity and laying out that roadmap.
Yeah.
And so when Pete and I reflect on sort
of where we've come from and where we're
going,
you know,
we really hope that something like our
manifesto is really going to remove this
question mark and we are going
to see customer lifetime value,
a common metric in every single business
and it will become a way to really
drive this strategy forward. So I want
to thank everybody for coming today.
Do you have any closing remarks?
Beat? No, we'd love to get your quick,
would love to get
questions. Yes, we would.
Alright,
go ahead.
Got a couple of microphones here.
What do y'all think? Huh? Please.
Thank you so much. That was
very, very interesting approach.
We really appreciate it.
I do have a question.
You mentioned the customer's interest
as intracity components of revenue.
Uh,
any advice that you can give us in terms
of how to lead those conversations with
the customers?
Given that we have so many variety of
them and their business models are very
different,
what would be a couple of key questions
that we can ask our clients to identify
those components for them?
It's true.
I really have to say that moving
the conversation over to early,
starting the conversation with the folks
in finance and then kind of backing
into marketing has been incredible
to get that kind of a abroad by it.
And especially from an audience,
it's not as afraid of of
models and forecasts and so
on. So here's the question.
Do you want to know what
your company's worth? I mean,
it's as simple as that and most of the
time more working with private equity
firms, late stage vcs who are looking
at a company they want to acquire.
But it becomes really interesting when
we're looking at a company and they just
know internally that they're really worth
a lot more than the market seems to be
saying. And they can't quite come
up with that rationale for it.
Still will turn to us to say,
so what are we really worth in
terms of the value of our customers?
So they can come up with the number,
hopefully higher than
what Wall Street thinks.
And then he'll make a whole big deal about
it. Not only that, the number's higher,
but to explain why that we've actually
been acquiring more customers that are
staying around longer than you think.
And again,
that translates directly
into the marketing, other
operational kinds of issues.
So I really think that that sometimes
starting on the finance side or maybe
doing that,
at least in parallel while you're doing
the less unusual but still difficult
marketing tactics, uh, but
you know, bringing it all
together I think is a very,
very convincing way to say that this,
this stuff's real.
Thank you.
Questions.
Look, I'm in teaching mode
right now. I will cold call.
So please.
So I think if there was like
a, the, the anti book for this,
it would be how brands grow.
Are you rolling?
No, no, no, no.
Yeah. So could you, could
you reconcile this does too.
I can. And of course I can get into
a pretty technical explanation of it,
but I'll, I won't. Um,
if you don't know how brands grow by
Byron Trump actually highly recommended
because he doesn't talk about
the models or anything like that.
But the models I'm talking about are very,
very,
very similar to the models are
underlying a lot of his principles.
So I actually agree with,
with most of what he's saying.
I agree with the idea that that when you
have that incremental dollar to spend,
Byron sharp says grow your base.
You must have more buyers.
I agree, but for a different reason,
I say let's focus more on acquisition.
Let's go out there and find more valuable
customers and not worry so much about
trying to fatten up the ones that we have.
So it's actually a lot
of alignment with it.
Now there are some
differences and I have the,
the ultimate love hate relationship with
Byron Sharp, uh, the, uh, that a bird.
And just to kind of summarize the,
the, the biggest difference, um,
the Cov distribution that I show,
the fact that we got the, this,
this tale of people out
there that kinda sticks out.
I was going to say like a sore
thumb, but a very healthy thumb. Um,
he doesn't really believe in that.
Uh, he, he kind of believes that, uh,
it's not something he
believes in Heterogeneity,
but not that there's much as much
of, as kind of a skew to it. Uh,
as we see in the actual data.
So a lot of my career has been taking
the kinds of models that Byron Sharp and
other folks have been building and then
kind of adding slight little bells and
whistles to them to kind of capture
reality a little bit better so that the
basic fundamental principles,
double jeopardy, all that
kind of stuff, um, holds a,
but there's actually more to it and then
it leads to, to other kinds of advice.
So, so we're, we're actually,
it might seem surprising and I don't
blame you for thinking that way,
but there's a surprising amount
of alignment. They're great.
And I will even say that, you know,
as we were pulling those together,
and I was going to try to
get Sarah into this world,
one of the early things that I did,
maybe one of the first books I pulled
off the shelf was that red covered books.
Say you gotta read this one too.
Awesome. Thank you. Thank you. So we have
a question here from, I'm not sure where,
but I'll read it.
Uh,
is Dov reserve relative to relatively
large companies with a lot of resources,
um, or is it applicable to small
companies as well? So Pete,
do you want to take a stab or you want
go for it? Flow. Okay. All right. So,
so what we think here is that this is the,
these are universal principles for sure.
Um,
when you're thinking about your customers,
it's also one thing you have to be worried
about is the over investment, right?
So if you're overinvesting in
customers that really aren't worth it,
that's something that will happen to you
regardless of the size of your company.
The other thing that we work really
hard at in the book, in fact,
we've structured the book in
such a way that we're talking,
we're trying to train your eye to look
at acquisition, retention, development,
and then understand time.
There's a time component to that where
you are in the maturity of your company,
whether you're large or small,
and how that changes your tactics.
We're talking about being nimble,
about experimenting.
Like I said before about testing your
hypotheses. And these are principles,
especially in the, you know, the era of
data that we're in that are applicable,
whether you're large or small.
And let me just to add to that,
cause in an era where we're every day
we're talking about the retail apocalypse
and all this kind of thing, I'm actually
very about it and I think that the,
the future rises from the small companies,
those digitally native
directly consumer companies,
many of which are right
around here. Um, there,
I don't want to say that there had
kind of textbook customers centricity
examples, but there are a heck of a
lot better than their older, bigger,
slower brethren. And so, so
again, implicitly or explicitly,
they're starting to embrace
a lot of these ideas.
They're starting to tag and track.
Customers calculate COVs a lot earlier
than traditional companies would.
And what's happening is those big old
companies are starting to take them a lot
more seriously instead of dismissing
them as a passing fad or just a little
teeny tiny niche. They're saying we can
learn a lot from them. You know what,
let's hire some of them to start running
our marketing or our whole company.
So I think a lot of these ideas are
kind of working their way up and it's
sometimes it's the little
companies leading the way. Renee.
Hi, thank you guys both for um, for today.
Kind of related to that last point,
is there a certain threshold now,
so much size of company but maybe
thresh hold up data right that you need.
So for instance, do you need five,
5,000 customers or 5 million?
Do you need two years,
three years or five years of transaction
data to actually make that model work?
Like what's the thresholds?
Because that will definitely tell us.
He may be a small company
growing very rapidly,
but then you hit a certain threshold
of customers but you don't have enough
years or enough data to actually make
the model work. Any thoughts like that?
Absolutely.
And know I sort of almost implicitly
answered the question when I was talking
about the kinds of companies that we
work with on customer base corporate
valuation.
I said late stage VC's,
we can't really do it at the early stages
for exactly the reasons you pointed
out that you don't have enough customers
to really see or or estimate that full
CLV distribution and in terms of the kind
of length of the runway that you need.
It's kind of interesting that I
don't need a long runway of date.
I need enough customers,
but I don't need a long amount of time
in order to estimate these models.
But I still don't really trust them
until I have about two or three years.
And why is that? Because one of the
issues that we haven't spoken about,
but it would make a big
deal about it in the book,
and I can't say enough about it in
practice or cohorts of customers,
we always run these models for a given
group of customers generally who we
acquired at the same time.
And the issue is that the cohorts are
not all created equal and that as we go
over times,
we get that first cohort of customers
required soon after we were founded.
They tend to be much better customers.
And so we don't want to just kind
of calculate CLV is on them and say,
where are an amazing company? Hey,
let's raise some more capital. Um,
so we need enough time to see a bunch of
the different cohorts we have to play,
connect the dots across them.
You've got to watch them
start to stabilize a little
bit so we can anticipate
what the subsequent in
the kind of steady state,
mature cohorts are going to look like.
So yes,
we do need enough customers
to see the heterogeneity.
We do need enough of a runway to see the
cross colar dynamics and obviously we
do need enough,
you know,
cleanliness of data to trust
those results in the first place.
Sometimes these models that I endorse,
sometimes they're too good that they'll
work really well even when you kind of
put in crappy data and it gives you this
false sense of security about it. So,
so all the issues you raised are right
on the money. And with that in mind,
I recognize that most companies aren't
born to do customer centricity right out
of the gate. We're going to be
born around a particular product.
We just want them to look ahead and
start doing all that tagging and tracking
costs. Two, three years later. Maybe
it's time to do that, pivot towards it,
but it's going to take some time.
Great. Thank you. Hey, I don't know,
we don't want to hold people hostage here.
See if there's time for any
other pressing issues. If not,
you got our contact info over here.
Uh,
and we are absolutely delighted to
keep the conversation going. As I,
as I said before,
this really is the first time
that we've presented this content.
A book's only been out for a few weeks,
so we're very much open all your
questions, but, but feedback, uh,
and just kinda tell us how we can spread
the gospel of customer centricity and
how we can help you do it more
effectively as well. So with that,
I want to thank Neil and the rest of
the team over here for giving us this
opportunity and for all of you for
taking the time and best wishes on your
customers and your journey.